nous avons préparé le breuvage en
associant les vertus c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre du théâtre baroque
espagnol sur scène l'un des dinosaures
du théâtre français gérard desarthe 60
ans sur les planches et toujours ce même
amour pour le verbe
j'ai dit oui à ces mythes parce que
l'oeuvre contexte lorsque l'oeuvre est
importante parce que l'oeuvre est
classique et qu'elle a tout ce qu'on a
perdu depuis sur dénis autant c'est à
dire le verbe une langue des situations
gérard desarthe du un roi nommé résine
qui croit que son fils sigismond porte
malheur il le kart du trône et choisit
de l'enfermer loin des êtres humains
et si c'est de céder face aux
dispositions il retournera dans sa
prison
ça me questionne comment étaient nos
ancêtres l'histoire comme en voilà avec
le comment fonctionner je veux dire
voilà quelque part à cette époque là on
veut voir la rouille la royauté
s'humilier devant dieu et pourtant il
est roi divin mais l'église est
tellement puissante que quelque part
effectivement voilà ce que c'est ça
c'est ça qui m'intéresse
regarde avec effroi
elle aussi n'a pas hésité à se lancer
dans l'aventuré du classique une
puissance une vraie présents sur scène
on reparlera probablement de cette jeune
actrice talentueuse qui joue le rôle de
rose le ciel m'a conduit en ce lieu
aujourd'hui afin sans doute que je sois
content j'ai commencé ce musée pour
faire du théâtre est encore au mieux que
ça j'ai commencé ce métier pour faire du
têt classique le personnage de rose
c'est une jeune fille qui au début de la
pièce vient avec clairon interprété par
dominique pinon se venger
du prince ashton qui d'après ce qu'on
comprend l'a déshonorée pour se marier à
la princesse étoiles d'un autre pays
inconscience modique vous ramasserez
volontiers le tout jeune on peut
imaginer qu'elle a 16 ans et elle a une
fougue elle a peur de rien et elle est
même téméraire en fait mais elle va
rencontrer son père c'est très complexe
mais c'est magnifique
la vie est un songe est un spectacle
populaire sur le libre arbitre et le
déterminisme un texte qui nous rappelle
avec délectation que rien n'est joué à
l'as vence et qu'il ne faut jamais plié
devant les contingences et les
contraintes de toutes sortes